executive editor of the Common Sense
Society Molly Hemingway Fox News
contributor Molly where am I wrong here
well this is this is a really
interesting and important point you have
people who are talking about being at
the Reagan library and what they seem to
be wanting to emphasize there is foreign
policy and that is an important thing to
emphasize the Cold War policies that
Reagan that Reagan used to win the Cold
War uh those are not the policies of
Mitch McConnell or George W bush and the
Republican party does do well with does
do well with that foreign policy but
there was something about the Reagan Era
that really worked well where Reagan
reached out reached out to workingclass
voters and managed to grow the party he
brought in so many Democrats you call
them Reagan democrats that's something
that really does work well for the
Republican Party caring about those
economic issues caring about also some
of these social issues an auto worker
doesn't just care about having good
income and having good wages and
benefits he also doesn't want his kid to
be taught to trans in the first grade
you know there all these issues that do
matter to average Americans and I have
to say Stephen Miller's with us as well
Stephen I mean those numbers out of
Michigan for the average family there
and what's happened to them are
devastating and now we're going to
apparently allow in millions and
millions of other voters over the next
uh year and if it's next four years
probably what 15 million Molly something
like that Chris uh but Stephen how much
damage is this doing to the average
family's budget what they're having to
spend every week and every
month well they're getting attacked from
all sides that's why globalization and
open borders and inflationary spending
are going to be Central in 2020 Working
Families cannot keep up they have low
skilled workers driving down incomes
they have run away out of control
spending in Washington that's making
their dollar worthless and they have
trade policies that Force American
workers in Michigan to compete with
actual slave labor in foreign countries
I don't care what kind of Economic
Policy you have as long as you're
competing with child labor and slave
labor American workers are going to lose
and that is the reason why there is a
transformational moment that could occur
for Republicans if they choose to tap
into that public angst Laura well Chris
we asked um Fox digital to talk to
people in San Diego about just the issue
of gas prices now they're over $6 there
watch it's crazy I was just about to
take a picture and send it to my friends
who are in the uh Midwest and show them
how crazy it is here yeah I remember
when it used to be like $2 and I could
fill up with like $20 like most of my
paychecks go to gas how much does it
cost you to fill up your gas tank
$88 uh about $75 I pay something $100
[Music]
150 have you had to choose between
filling up your gas tank and buying
other things oh actually yes a couple
times it's been either groceries or gas
and I'm like gas prices have gone up but
what about your pay no I'll stay the
same Chris this one issue I think could
win the whole election just the issue of
gas prices that's brutal I mean I drive
a 1994 truck and I got it from
California a lot of people in California
Drive old Vehicles they keep them up and
they it gets them outside of all the
restrictions the govern new's put on
them their ability to drive actual
Vehicles so they have to go with these
older ones it's cost over $100 every
time I fill up I have to fill up a
couple times just driving dropping my
kid off at school just making it to work
and that hits your wallet every time you
stop at the grocery store it's 150 bucks
but I'm wondering exactly who these GOP
candidates on the stage tonight are
going to be talking to I mean the voters
the Republican voters seem like they've
got a pretty clear preference for Donald
Trump but who doesn't is the Republican
donor class and the Senators like
mconnell
would they rather have Biden be
president I think they actually might
ukra for them the absolutely and you
know so he they're trying to talk to the
finance guys the finance guys and
everyone else were trying to back anyone
other than Trump early on they had to
Sis who you're not going to argue with
him on his record it's a great record
but he's not been doing well they've
been losing faith in that so tonight
they're going to be looking at that
screen saying who's going to who's going
to agree with me on Ukraine who's going
to agree with the finance class on this
or that and they're going to go with
that Nikki Haley is out there maybe is
someone and you look at VI R Swami he he
just separated himself other the debate
but being the only person out there with
a foreign policy that sounded like the
voters so maybe maybe he's going to be
under attack today but everyone else is
going for that fight Molly what what of
this I mean there nothing personal
against anybody I mean they're really
interesting people and nice people and
they they've all had positions of of of
some you know Prestige but the voters
have been very clear on the issues they
care about and it it seems like the
donors are saying no no no no no can't
do it and Senate leadership no no no no
no but I mean we are supposed to be a
representative democracy are we not
aren't don't the people have their say
in the end and this does happen in other
primary situations as well it's really
pronounced right now the people could
not be more clear about their concern
about the direction of the country they
really do think things are serious they
are very worried about the economy and
they're clear also that they do not want
to have yet another endless war in
Ukraine without you know with a war
without a strategy the people who run
Washington DC do not care what the
American people think they're beholden
to other interests but tonight there's a
real opportunity the candidate who does
articulate concern for foreign policy
that matches what American voters have
wanted and consistently that they have
done well with from the 50s 67s America
First AR aren't those two words Stephen
don't those two words capture where
people's mindset happens to be now that
we feel terrible about all these other
problems but ours we're bad we're in a
bad spot right now
the voters want America First the donors
want Ukraine first that's the fight you
see right now between Mitch McConnell's
Republican party and Donald Trump's
Republican party and that is going to be
the issue that defines the struggle
within the Republican party for some
time to come and like you Laura I hope
the populace Prevail all right P hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else